well I Lachlan how are you coming in Oh
coming in and rolling off the table I'm
here you've got to love like where
you're at right now I do man no not just
in terms of lighting because I mean
nothing that ever completely went away
but the rejuvenated obsession with Twin
Peaks just has you like I can't tell you
how many people I told yesterday you
were coming in and they're like it's
just so cool to see you know thanks
mentor the fans are definitely intense
yeah Twin Peaks fans bless their hearts
I mean they are they've been following
this they've been wanting us to happen
for 25 26 at 27 years now so are you
glad that it took this long so so you
know poetically it made sense that we
left it and said we'll see you in 25
years yeah and 26 years later here we
are I think it was fun and I also going
back to the fans I mean I think they
were largely responsible for getting
David and Mark to start thinking again
about are there any more stories that
they want to tell they just kept the
drumbeat going you know how long was it
in the works for before it finally I
said okay we're gonna do it like how
well it was the year that they thought
about it or you know they I think once
they kind of came together and found the
way back in it didn't take long I know
early on the process David reached out
to me and said I need to talk with you
and but I can't talk with you over the
phone
so we met in New York where he was
staying and he said we're gonna go back
to Twin Peaks and he wanted to know if I
won if I was up for going back and I
said David I said I never left please so
so from that point on to when we finally
started filming was a boy it's about a
year and a half so David Lynch Square
said because is what did we had Jhansi
McKinley and he was talk about Oliver
Stone and now he's a guy who has a
vision and that's it and you have to fit
in his vision David Lynch on the outside
seems like kind of a crazy guy when you
work with him as he is he kind of
collaborative or does he have a vision
and you gotta fit into it nuts it super
collaborative oh yes yeah and and it's
just kind of a regular guy it just
happens at the worlds he creates and
lives in or obviously highly unusual so
when you step on the set with him it's
the it's just the greatest environment
in the world very collaborative there's
just a lot of joy there's a lot of love
going on and
really he really just depends upon the
involvement of his actors he's not a
yellow or a streamer not at all I think
he's a unbelievable talent but I'm just
terrified of him don't worry about those
just in his head Robert Blake creepier
when they first announced that it was
they so when it comes out that this is
happening and short times gonna do it
never you know there was a moment where
David Lynch was like I'm not getting
involved in this you know this before it
started filming everything that was like
it almost looked like it wasn't gonna
happen or at least it wasn't gonna
happen with David Lynch was there ever
before it happened this fear for you
that oh my god I've already agreed to do
this and if David Lynch isn't doing it
it's not gonna work
well the only way it would be Twin Peaks
is if David was so would you have been
able to step out and say well I mean
there was there was nothing going
forward yeah I don't know what that what
the plans were I don't I know David just
felt like the he had a vision he had a
way that he wanted to do it that he felt
he needed to do it and that was why he
and David Nevins at Showtime sat down
and and they worked through whatever
issues there were I don't think it was
that big of a deal and if it came to an
agreement then so they kept going
forward but I was yeah I was
disappointed when I heard that it might
not right now happen let's say they came
to you though and they said all right we
got [ __ ] Mick G you know that old
director from the oh yeah all the 90s
videos he's gonna come in and do it
would you have done it with him I mean
you know it's probably not I mean the
only way that works the twin peaks'
works is with David what was the first
thing you ever auditioned for and got do
you remember uh yeah dune actually that
was your friend that was my first movie
that was 83 yeah up to that point I
would just been doing theater I noticed
how big of a part did you have been
doing it was it was small part uh he was
the pretty much the lead is the ruler of
the known universe
a small part
you for the leader of the known universe
can you handle it I think so did you
really went to school turn down the part
of input into Charlie Sheen plate you
know Oliver met and we talked about it
and he wanted me to do it and I
hesitated they was in I got a member was
in completely different situation so it
was a Dino De Laurentiis at that time
the eg production and I had an ax
contract with Dino from dune I was
signed up for the rest of my life almost
at that time so I just I didn't really
respond to it and get back to Oliver and
then blue velvet came along and I was
like okay I'm gonna do blue velvet and
then and then Oliver took platoon
elsewhere and then the name was Charlie
did you ever look back on I always
wonder if guys look back on that we
everyone says yes and no and platoon may
have been what it was because of Charlie
but you ever look back I think I could
have done a good job in that been a part
of it I mean I could have done a good
job and it would have been an incredible
adventure I you know but then where I am
now who knows if that would have
happened because then if you didn't do
blue valve David gave me the script of
blue velvet when we were shooting dune
so I felt well this is and I really
liked David you know and I said this is
and blue velvet was as you know if
you've all seen it but you're incredibly
disturbing compelling film yeah so I was
like this one really this one really
excites me you know so if you don't do
blue velvet right then you probably
don't get to Twin Peaks quite possibly
and then so that becomes the thing in
your mind is like where your choices
decisions I mean at the time you sort of
look back but then as you get older I
think you look back so you know actually
this all worked out the way it suposed
exactly it's this actor butterfly effect
thing I remember hearing a Julia
louis-dreyfus from being interviewed and
she said when she auditioned for
Seinfeld and they offered her the part
she was genuinely concerned it was a bad
career move
just like this thing you just never you
don't really know like you know you can
see a great script or attack you know
you don't know what's gonna be like this
huge thing and then you got to go
imagine things like I'm not gonna make
any money off this thing and she
probably made like a billion dollars
yeah successfully she was so great and
into yeah yeah what was a Dennis Hopper
how much interaction did you have with
him quite a bit actually
I'm blue
and Dennis had been rehab for a couple
years and just the greatest guy way he
was in rehab for a couple years he had
been yeah he'd start he had clean you'd
been clean and sober for a couple Oh
actually in a rehab for a couple years
okay no no but he'd been clean for for a
while and was just the greatest guy so
totally together perfect for Frank very
frightening I always say I didn't have
to do much as an actor but react to him
right and he was kind of Apocalypse Now
I don't think he was sober I don't think
so that would I love that amazing people
blasted Brando in it the critics killed
Brando I thought he was great unbeliev
it was just weird and quiet and shadowed
and just bizarre dialogue were you from
Willis Willard where are you from yeah
is that great the just I love it you
know what comfortable that's been from
Martin Sheen after stay there and look
at Brando in this hot room and your
improv him with this [ __ ] very
uncomfortable yeah absolutely
yeah so when you're working with David
Lynch I don't have I'm not asking starts
pink you do you this seems that like we
as viewers will watch and like try to
figure out because I think that's part
of the attraction of Twin Peaks right is
that you're watching and and it always
it provokes discussion at the very least
absolutely do you know what Lynch's
intentions are in these scenes or does
he keep all that close to the vest deep
he keeps it pretty close to the vest and
I don't grill him on it I really just
concentrate on what I need to know as an
actor and my journey through I had heard
that he brought on the who was the
actress from the first season that he
brought on and played an Asian man
Raquel Welch after she was off the no
works for me I had that image in my head
straightaway come on right got your head
but he one of the characters in the
first season right came back as an Asian
man I didn't even know about this it was
alright I'm watching this video right
like the 8 things you didn't know about
Twin Peaks right yeah there's like
conspiracy theory videos they said and I
David Lynch used to make all the cast
members make out with each other before
every scene it was dark
mister told you Maura do you remember
that character no okay so that was an
actress that had already been on the
show okay
killed off her was written off or
whatever okay and so what I saw on the
video it said that Lynch didn't tell
anybody on the set that this was that
actress and that she showed up in full
makeup and then all the actors were told
that this was like a Asian actor right
because very very famous in Japan or
someone like that would yeah is that
something the great is that I would feel
like I don't I'm like trusting you to be
the director yeah he loves that kind of
stuff we have a lot of laughing laughs
on the set yeah yeah he loves a good
joke so he wouldn't necessarily do that
as some kind of mysterious method he
would do that as like this will be funny
funny totally like that why when you
work with a guy like that who's
collaborative and you're having fun on
the set then you have to go work with
somebody who's not collaborative and all
of a sudden you know hood is not gonna
be as well-received everything is
different every situation is different
you just did guys and actually you kind
of roll with the punches do what you
need to do but I kind of say by and
large the directors that I work with are
all I mean I think they all need the
actors contribution and they all you
know know that some are some are more
open and sort of more available than
others but they're all pretty much the
same who was it that said was it Jeff
Daniels but I had and it said that I
think it's a Sorkin he said like he
wants it she has a letter letter yeah
the way he wrote that's his vision he's
just a very I guess controlling with his
vision you know and you know obviously
it's successful but he said Lee you have
to be a hundred percent ready all the
key doesn't [ __ ] around like some guys
just wanted a certain way and I'm
actually Siri talking talking sorry his
writing is very important its rhythmic
it's there for a purpose you know so I I
get that about Aaron how do you know I
never met him a few times he's brilliant
obviously but and that's usually the
case in television in particular writers
they want you to sort of you know they
put it in there for a reason so you've
got to go with anything want to make any
changes you ask ahead of time but but by
and large you just go with what's there
film can be is slightly more
you know flexible I think why you think
that is I think you have more time and
the director is right there and the
right is right there and sometimes with
with television the writing staff
something is setting something up for a
future episode or the writers are maybe
not so close by they're in the writers
room you're on the set so to get there
okay to make a change Scott takes time
it costs you time that's a good point
too about setting something up for a
later episode it could be this is
something like that ya know are you
comfortable asking if you want to change
something yeah oh yeah if there's
something I read I I might I'll send a
couple notes in but you would say I
think one like remember on the set I
went I literally said I went bang yeah
let me go cut they're like hey that was
great could you just not say the word
bang could you not shoot like a
five-year-old boy yeah things like you
you have you go into that thing and I
would rather just read the words as is
instead of improv yeah dude I don't know
man it's so uncomfortable acting in
general just trying to be somebody else
is the hardest thing in the world I
don't like I'd like to say things my own
way it's usually little things doesn't
change the meaning but there's certain
phrases that are just a little easier to
say a certain way like I would never
speak like that even though you're
playing someone else you're still still
I would never use yeah yeah or or or you
know a period here
I heard that Christopher Walken when he
gets to script and which is probably why
he's so interesting will will write out
his dialogue or someone right - that
removes all punctuation I do that
sometimes
why all my impersonation sound the same
yeah go Manchu Asian or he has his own
way own way of speaking rhythmic
rhythmically and stuff but um and I
think that too is sometimes it's easier
to say something's a certain way or not
but then on the other side you go away
yeah but maybe it's kind of good for the
character that it's a little bit awkward
and you should say it this way so then I
make that argument and try and confuse
myself yeah but what type that type of
stuff you'll you'll change something
like like I don't see the character
doing this or like I would never say it
in this way no I used to go off just my
reaction and chicken Wednesday I'll go
change this and now I'm kind of like
well let me live with it and see what it
really does how it affects the character
or that scene of that moment or the
reaction what I'm trying to get from the
person across me so I give it more of a
chance now actually so you'll actually
do it the way they just see what comes
and see if I can make it work or why
it's there
do you at all get tired of the fact that
especially now that the series is back
in the zeitgeist and every time you take
a sip of coffee whoever is around you is
just looking at you to see if is he
gonna say the line they're gonna spit
out the comment I get a lot of free
coffee which is nice yeah you know I've
always loved coffee so that's easy but
it's you know it's fun being Becca's
Cooper he's like it's a great character
he's you great care are there like it
was because I've seen you as coop and
obviously I watched you on Sex in the
City many times probably first of all
how many [ __ ] Cougs are throwing it
at you
[Laughter]
what's like the the most out-there roll
away from your personality because you
you you're sitting here and I feel like
I'm talking to coop I feel like I'm
talking to your couch from second city
in fact that's not like out there for
your personality type what is the the
craziest thing you've done where it's
like that's just not me and that's the
thing that's like really hard as an
actor I think don't completely away that
myself you know ya know it was the role
of in the current Twin Peaks where I
play character we known as either the
doppelganger evil coupe or mr. C and he
used a character that was completely
different departure for me I mean he was
no humanity remorseless just a bad bad
guy like me pretty much fact and that
was really challenging and took me a
while to sort of get into that place but
was ultimately really successful and
David Lynch was tremendous help yeah
theatre background just you I'm assuming
you can like you know it's almost like
you know fighters can fight different
selves you could do anything so face
told you to come in and be like a drug a
drug kingpin from the hood
could you go play that well I'd have to
find my own way in on that that would be
tricky you played claw as a Claudius and
Hamlet yeah I've never seen Hamlet but I
imagine this a difficult role to play
Shakespeare seems like a really
uncomfortably hard thing to do
it's challenging for sure but it's the
writing is amazing and when you start
saying those words and you get into the
rhythm of the poetry it just you realize
why he's so brilliant it just makes
complete sense as an actor it really I
don't know it's something about saying
those words of really hurry I'm not as
educated as Jim so I don't I don't know
anything about these these Hamlet but we
have a low bar here I've always been
curious about the film show life of
course I was just waiting
so which I masturbated to you I was a
part of it absolutely he said the same
thing with Kevin Bacon came in when that
movie is coming out I think it was the
director behind it was trying to enforce
upon everybody that this is not this
kind of gratuitous movie that you think
it is it's actually this much bigger
thing and there's a religious
connotation to it and it's this big big
picture thing that he sees and then
people went and saw it and they were
like no were you were you of the opinion
that the movie was going to be as he
described it or as we assumed it was and
then found out it was the first working
title Saved by the Bell totes bells
should have been it was no when I signed
on I thought I read it as he was
describing I say oh this is gonna be
pretty kind of a brilliant expose of
Vegas it's Paul Verhoeven amazing
director I happen to love Robocop it's
one of my favorite movies I was like
okay this is gonna be very basic
instinct was pretty incredible Esterhaus
wrote the script so you know you're like
okay that's two good things and then you
got an interesting story an unknown girl
playing the lead great and I got to play
the idea was I got to play a character
that was off type for me so I was that
kind of he was a kind of a sleaze bag
and I thought oh this could be
interesting to do so put all that
together I was like yeah I'll give it a
shot cut - yeah and during the filming I
was like this actually looks like it's
pretty good the show they've made
amazing shows it did the scenes were
okay I was in okay so what do you do
show up at the premiere and go what the
fire yeah I was just like this oh my
gosh how far into it at the premiere
were you like had you seen it before
pretty much no I had pretty much the
first scene I said okay okay we're in
trouble
yeah it was it was embarrassing it was
you know with one of those things where
well and that one didn't go right you
know so what do we do why don't we just
keep moving for you feel like a sense of
ownership of it or do you kind of just
move away from anger all right well I
[ __ ] up I should have taken that role
you know it's found and it's found a
great audience like you were saying it's
too
something that's sort of a classic camp
camp classic as they say and it's got an
audience
yeah people loved watching it they have
fun they have a good laugh it is
entertainment right we're in the
business of entertainment after all so
it's found its way it wasn't I don't
think the intention of the original
intention but you know it's kind of life
afterwards so Soviet lives on can I ask
you another question about a thing I saw
in the in the conspiracy videos about
Twin Peaks you're spending far too much
time so this is and this is like you
know 30-year old gossip at this point
but who killed Laura is the reason that
your characters relationship with the
Audrey character is the reason that that
kind of fizzled out after like the first
season or whatever because you were in a
relationship and the person with Lara
Flynn Boyle hmm and she was
uncomfortable with the on scene onset
chemistry that you guys had no the main
reason was I felt the main reason was
because she's in high school Audrey's in
high school right and I just felt you
know what Cooper is not this we can push
things and we do but I said that that is
just not a place that I'm comfortable
going with that care really so I was
like so I was like you know that he has
to take the high ground on this so I
fought for that oh you actually did yeah
yeah so that other thing is just gossip
and conspiracy Joe was your chick I
don't like how it's getting crazy even
if what there was doing there wasn't
anything I mean it was ABC what was
gonna happen right it was like nothing
gonna happen so but sometimes I guess if
you're playing somebody like that just
doesn't it just doesn't work for me or
yeah I don't think that the character
would do this as part of the Rose now as
part of the process of television so you
know you have there are arcs and things
that are developed but the writers will
you know take stories where they want to
take them and you aren't as you sign up
for something you don't necessarily know
where it's gonna go you have kind of an
idea but sometimes
they go on tangents and I'm comfortable
saying you know what I'm not sure the
guy would be ugly pathway yeah how about
I make suggestions and stuff but that's
pretty typical for television so
television so yesterday we had a our
friend Michael malleus who's an expert
on North Korea come in and he explained
all North Korea stones and he's one of
the people who just flipped when he
found out that you were coming yes so he
insisted that I ask you a question from
him he's gonna send in questions he sent
me a clue this is the question that you
really wanted his wife missed a nuclear
war so Michael Malins his theory is that
the ending of the show meant that no
matter where you and Sheryl Lee go or
what you do you'll still always be agent
Cooper and Laura Palmer what do you
think
well the ending was pretty intense I
haven't seen it yeah so I can't I would
say but do you think that that theory
holds water is Mike a blithering idiot
no yeah more no doubtful about this I'm
rejecting all the stuff he told me about
North Korea it's I just say you know
what all theories are valid at this
point because I don't know I mean I
watched it and I came away scratching my
head as well the thing I do know is it's
hard to see Cooper who's always got
things under control suddenly in a
moment where he's at a loss and he is
not sure of himself or what's just
happened and that I think was more
disturbing than anything else for me as
the character just like whoa whoa he's
got to come back from that somehow yeah
unfortunately it had been no discussions
about future shows or anything so I
don't know where they are with that what
do you do if they did if they were like
okay they did yeah I mean a season a
movie whatever the character well we
know you live quite a spoiler because
the show did air already but yeah and
that's probably what you're promoting is
Twin Peaks to return the entire season
is available on Showtime on demand yes
get there on the Twin Peaks actually the
first show I didn't like think about
this as you said that the whole seasons
available to impeach is a first show
that I ever binge watched
this is before Netflix might my friend
Katie who Dave you know she literally
had it on huge HS yeah she really was
but she everyone sorry but she had him
on VHS literally from the original
airing and we binge watch them over the
Conchords him off TV HS copies